presenter: Hi everyone thanks for joining
us today.
I'm Joy Cohen a crew development manager here
at Google.
I just wanted to remind everyone before we
get started the books are on sale in the back
for $5.00.
We are very pleased to welcome Rich Horwath
for an at Google talk.
He comes to us with a plan, a plan to experience
more of what life has to offer.
He's the author of "Strategy For You: Building
a Bridge to the Life You Want."
Using principles of strategic thinking, Rich
offers advice for finding what you truly want.
He offers a five-step program towards managing
your career and your life.
Rich is the CEO of Strategic Thinking Institute
where he's helped over 50,000 managers develop
their strategic thinking skills.
He's also the publisher of the monthly digest,
"The Strategic Thinker."
We'll have time for Q and A at the mikes at
the end.
Please join me in welcoming Rich to Google.
[Applause]
>>Rich: Thanks Joy, I appreciate it.
Thanks.
So this past Saturday morning I'm sitting
in my home office it's about seven o'clock
and I'm listening to a CD that I'd recorded
a few days earlier on strategy.
I was just checking to see if I needed to
make any changes.
At about 7:30 my eight-year-old son, named
Luke, came into the room and he plops down
on the big brown leather chair.
And I watch him listen for about a minute
or so and finally, being the dad, I had to
ask, "So Luke,what you think of dad's new
CD on strategy?"
I'm excited right?
And he goes, "It sounds like church."
[Laughter]
And so not putting that together right away
I say, "Well church, how is it like church?"
He said, "Well, there's a lot of talking,
I don't understand most of it and I think
I'm getting sleepy."
[Laughter]
And in fairness to Luke, I think discussions
sometimes of strategy can be that way.
But not usually when we apply strategy to
you, which is what we're going to do today.
You know there's a simple but often overlooked
premise in life, and that is new growth comes
from new thinking.
New growth comes from new thinking.
Expecting new growth for your career, for
your business, for your relationships, for
your finances without new ways of thinking
about them is like a farmer expecting new
crops to grow without first planting the seeds.
And that's really the goal of this session
this afternoon is to give you some new concepts,
some new tools to think strategically about
your life, your work, your relationships,
your career.
Okay?
And so as we do that, we're gonna talk a little
bit about strategy overall and obviously being
here at Google you understand strategy better
than most.
But we're gonna talk not just about business
strategy but how do you take some of those
key principles of strategy, principles that
have been around thousands of years and actually
use them to be happier, more successful however
you define success in your life.
And when we think about strategy, really what
we're thinking about is here is where we are
today; here's where we want to go.
Strategy is the bridge that takes us from
where we are to where we want to go.
So from a business standpoint, many of you
have goals and objectives for your plans for
the year.
The strategy, as you know, is how you get
from where you are today to reach those goals
and objectives.
From a personal perspective strategy is looking
at where are you right now your life?
Mind, body, relationships, finances, spirituality.
And where do you really want to be with those
different areas?
You know a lot of times we bounce around from
one thing to the next like a pinball, with
no real direction.
And strategy, or that bridge can kind of give
us that direction.
It can help channel what we're good at, what
we like to do, who we like to help from a
profit or nonprofit perspective and we can
find ways to do that effectively and in ways
that other people value.
You know great strategy is not just from a
business standpoint or a political standpoint
or a military standpoint, it's designed to
help us take back that power in our lives.
I don't know about you but often times I feel
a little bit like I don't have control.
Things are going in a lot of different directions,
I'm bouncing around.
Strategy is a way to take some of that control
back.
To take some of that direction back.
So in 15 years, 20 years, 25 years, we can
look back and say you know what I did the
most with what I have.
The biggest thing we don't want to do, and
when you interview folks that are in their
70s and 80s and 90s the biggest thing is folks
looking back with regret to say I could have
maybe done this for work or I could have maybe
been in this relationship or I could've maybe
volunteered more often, but I didn't do it.
So we want to do today is talk a little bit
about how do we do that?
How do we make sure we realize our full potential?
And really as we talk today, we're gonna be
talking about how do you make those decisions?
Just out of curiosity how many folks here,
show of hands, how many of you have a written
business plan for the group that you work
with?
Just a show of hands, any of you guys ever
written a business plan for what you do?
Okay, maybe about half, a third.
How about personally, how many folks have
a written plan, doesn't have to be a 20 page
plan because we know those never get used.
But how many folks have written down some
of their goals professionally, personally
and then how you're going to get there?
Okay, so good maybe about 25-30% that's actually
more than we normally see.
Because what the research shows, and I, in
the last couple years did research with about
2500 adults in the United States.
And what we found is that about 15% of adults
have a written plan for their lives.
So career, relationships, finances, spirituality
about 15%.
What was interesting is that we also did a
separate study looking at folks that worked
for Fortune 1000 companies.
So folks that were managers in Fortune 1000
companies and what we found was that only
22% of those folks had a written plan for
their life.
The interesting thing is when you look at
strategy for business we know that historically
and from a research perspective strategy is
very important to successful businesses.
There is just recently completed a 25 year
study on 750 bankrupt companies.
And what they found was that the number one
cause of bankruptcy over the last 25 years
was bad strategy.
So companies not having either establishes
strategy or working with a flawed strategy,
that was the number one cause of bankruptcy.
And today you open up the paper, you see companies
like United Airlines, Borders, companies that
we're very familiar with, bigger companies
sometimes going bankrupt.
So we do know in business, from a business
perspective, strategy's important.
From an individual perspective, as managers
potentially, strategy is also important.
There were two separate studies on leadership
published in the Wall Street Journal and Chief
Executive Magazine and both of those studies
on leadership found that the number one most
valued skill in leaders today is strategic
thinking.
But interestingly 50% of companies reported
that strategic thinking is the skill their
leaders most needed to improve.
And in the research for my previous book "Deep
Dive" what I found is that only about three
out of every 10 managers are strategic, so
about 30%.
So what we want to do today is say how can
we raise that level?
How can we take what we do day in and day
out and give it a little bit of direction?
Right?
None of us want to be pigeon-holed and say
in three years you're going to do this, in
five years you're gonna do this, in seven
years you're gonna do this, right?
We don't want that.
But what we do want is to take what we're
good at, what we're passionate about and channel
that so that we're using that as we move through.
What that looks like in three or four years
you might not know but we at least want to
have that mapped out so that we're making
progress and we're realizing our potential,
whatever that might be.
So as I did the research for this last book,
what we found is that there's roughly 5 steps
to developing a strategy for your life.
These also tend to coincide with business,
business strategies as well.
But for this, instance really five steps in
creating that strategy for life.
And so the five steps are number one discover,
secondly differentiate, third decide, fourth
design, and then fifth drive.
So what we're gonna do in the next half hour
or so is just kind of walk through each of
these areas and then I would certainly like
to open it up to any questions, comments,
observations that you might have from your
life and maybe some the things that you found
successful in driving or developing strategies
for yourselves.
So the first step is discover.
And discover means we've got to first understand
where are we today?
We've got to stop and say where are we today?
We've got to get an idea of what does our
situation look like.
And it's important for several reasons and
first we'll talk a little bit about Katie
Couric.
Maybe not the most flattering shot of Katie,
but we know Katie Couric for years and years,
very successful cohost of The Today Show with
Matt Lauer.
Year after year ranked number one.
About five years ago she went to the CBS evening
news and you can't blame her, 13-14 million
a year so that's incentive.
And each year though she was ranked dead last
in viewership.
Year after year.
Even about 500,000 viewers behind the anchor
who was in the seat from CBS that nobody knew
before her.
So we wonder, well, what happened to Katie
in that five-year time frame?
Did she just become a mumbling bumbling broadcaster?
And the answer is no.
What happened though is her situation changed.
Her context changed.
Who she was talking to, what she was talking
about, the time of day she was talking about,
all those things changed.
And because her situation changed it negatively
impacted her performance.
Or at least her perceived performance.
So one of the things we want to do is find
a way to understand what's going on in our
life.
Okay?
What's going on in our life.
And when you build a bridge one of the first
things that happens in addition to the surveying
things is you create a survey of the site
right?
Understand what's the composition of the ground
like, what's the distance we've gotta span,
where we going to take this bridge, what types
of materials might be appropriate?
So we create that survey or snapshot of what's
happening.
So we can do that for ourselves as well, and
most of the things we talk about today we're
gonna do visually because I think visually
[snap] tends to connect a little bit quicker.
So when we look at a survey of ourselves we
can potentially break it down into four areas.
And there's other areas we can consider, but
four we can consider for today are mind, body,
relationships and finances.
Mind, body, relationships, finances.
So when it comes to mind, things that we're
thinking about relative to potentially our
career, our work, our spirituality.
The things that tend to be top of mind day
in and day out.
From a body perspective, what's our health
like?
Are we in good shape?
Do we think we need to be in better shape?
Do we have a history of medical illnesses
that we need to be aware of?
What, from a physical body perspective, are
some of the key things that we need to think
about?
Relationships, family, friends, coworkers
where are we at with those?
Are they strong across the board?
Are we not spending as much time with kids
or with friends that we're close to because
works dominating?
So where are the relationships at?
And then finances.
And again as we move forward, if you have
families where are we financially?
Where do we want to be?
Do we have a plan for getting there?
So what we can do then is populate this tool
with kind of what's top of mind for us in
each of those areas.
So if we start with body, maybe we say you
know the few times that we have exercised
in the morning, it's really jump started our
day.
So that might be a key as far as getting our
plan set.
We know that when we're around the house diet's
pretty good but generally if we're traveling
we kind of fall off the wagon.
We're eating, drinking stuff that we shouldn't
be.
Relationship wise maybe we say you know I'm
not spending as much time with my friends
as I used to.
We've got maybe more family commitments, kids,
things like that.
But those relationships are still important,
how do we make sure they don't wither and
die?
We also might think about coworkers, you know
maybe we've got a new coworker; it's maybe
not going great right away.
How do we build that relationship so that
it becomes a stronger, more vital one to our
group?
Financially, what are we doing long-term?
What are we doing from a partner or spouse
perspective?
They want to go to Europe, how do we get that
set up so that happens?
And then from a mind perspective, we're thinking
about work.
What do we need to do to differentiate ourselves?
To move up in the organization, maybe get
more responsibility?
And then also are we looking for opportunities
to volunteer?
So again these are just some generic examples
but really what we want to do with this tool
is give ourselves a way to take a snapshot
of what's happening in our lives.
You've got it all kind of fluttering around
in your mind but if you don't put it on paper
it generally doesn't tend to provide that
foundation for the plan that we'll talk about
a few minutes.
So once you've taken a snapshot of what's
going on around you what we can then do is
start to think about where do we want to go?
And as we know most of the time we're setting
our goals.
And I developed a simple framework, I use
this with business managers primarily but
you can also apply it to your life.
Goals and objective, that part of GOST, goals
and objectives are what you're trying to achieve.
Strategy and tactics, how you are going to
get there.
And you say well sure Rich, everybody knows
that.
Not necessarily.
A couple years ago, one of the CEOs of a prominent
company out this way and I won't say the name
came out when she first started and said,
"The primary strategy for our company is to
grow our audience", which is terrific.
But that's not a strategy, that's the goal.
How you grow the audience is the strategy.
So as you think about this in relation to
yourself, your goals, what do you want to
achieve?
Whether it's work, whether it's your health,
whether it's relationships what specifically
do you want to achieve?
You've got to start with a goal then the objective.
We've heard smart, specific, measurable, achievable,
relevant, time-bound, so what specifically?
Strategy and tactics then is that bridge,
how you're going to get there.
Okay so let's look at couple examples.
Business wise we might have one that says
our goal is to win a quarterly sales contest
for our region.
The objective then more specifically what
we want to achieve, 200,000, 250,000 in sales
by the end of the third quarter.
Strategy, then, how generally are we going
to get there?
Focus our selling efforts on expanding share
of wallet with current customers.
And then tactically we might do a cell sheet,
video of customers using the products and
so forth.
How do we apply that then into our personal
lives?
The goal might be to lose weight.
We're just getting through the winter, I'm
from Chicago, we tend to eat a lot of stuffed
pizza in the winter.
So the goal might be to lose some weight.
The objective more specifically is lose 15
pounds in six months.
The strategy then, how generally are we going
to do it is to eliminate weight causing behaviors
and create healthy habits.
So tactically, specifically, we might do things
like try to drink more water as opposed to
those two or three sodas a day.
Get a treadmill, get some strength bands,
eat protein-based breakfasts, do some of those
things.
So again, many of you it sounded like are
doing this already but we've got to be able
to jot down the goal of what we're trying
to achieve the objective the strategy and
the tactic, OK?
So again we don't have a lot of time today
but one of the exercises I'd recommend is
take a few minutes, think about your work,
think about your relationships, think about
your finances, what are some of the goals?
And what are the strategies you going to use
to get there, OK?
About 1974 or I think it was roughly August
7th, a Frenchman by the name of Phillippe
Petit did something that no one had done before
and no one has done since.
He set up a wire, a 450 pound cable between
the twin towers of the World Trade Center
and for about an hour he walked on that high
wire 1350 feet above the streets of Manhattan.
Jumping, dancing, laying down, no harness,
no safety wire, nothing for about an hour.
And then finally was pulled off by the police
as it started to rain.
So we look at that and we say very interesting,
it was actually called the artistic crime
of the century.
And there's a great documentary called 'Man
on Wire' and it won the 2008 Academy Award
for best documentary if you haven't been seen
it it's fairly interesting.
And it documents what he did.
And some say, well you know it was just kind
of a spur of the moment, a whim, a lark and
actually that moment had been preceded by
six years of him planning with a group of
about 10 people in order to be able to set
this up and do it.
So at the end of the day, he took what's obviously
a very common activity which is walking and
he did it in a way that the people who've
seen it or seen the documentary will never
forget.
So he took a common activity and he made it
his own through his unique talent and his
unique passion.
And any time you develop strategy for your
career, for your business inherently there's
going to be risk.
If you're comfortable every day and everything
that you do you're probably not really maximizing
your potential.
Great strategy demands that you take risks.
Reed Hastings who, as many of you know I'm
sure, is the CEO of Netflix has said, "If
you don't feel pain when you're developing
strategy then you have not developed strategy."
So one of the things that I'd like you to
think about in the next few minutes is what
are some of the unique talents, the activities,
the passions that you have that others don't?
And how have you, in the past, used those
to bring value to yourself and to other people
around you.
So the second step in our process is differentiate.
You know when you look at most great companies
you can very quickly understand how they differentiate
themselves from the other companies they compete
with in order to be successful.
You know a company like yours obviously you've
driven a lot of your differentiation around
this idea of play from a culture perspective
because play leads to innovation which leads
to new value for customers.
So what I want you to think about is how do
we differentiate.
And I'll give you a couple more examples.
There's a British artist name Damien Hirst.
And Damien Hirst has become a very popular,
maybe infamous in some circles, artist because
what he's done is he's taken art and he's
done it very differently than most anyone
else out there in the world.
What he started to do, or what he's been doing
is taking animals, dead animals, okay, I'm
not a part of PETA, and if you are please
direct comments to Damien.
But he's been taking dead animals and putting
them in formaldehyde and using them in different
ways, different positions, different forms
to create artwork.
This is one of his most famous pieces.
Now we can argue all day is that art or is
it not art?
And I'm not gonna say which side I fall on,
but the reality is, by doing art in a different
way, a way that's meaningful to him, he's
become the most wealthy British living artist.
His net worth is about $350 million.
So again were not saying that's the be-all
end-all of art, but the reality is he's one
example of an artist whose done things differently
to be successful.
You look at an entertainer like Johnny Cash.
We know Johnny Cash, American singer-songwriter.
When you listen to his recordings never the
best voice really, but what made him successful,
what made him endeared to many people is his
ability to tell a true authentic story in
a way that resonated with people.
Another example of doing things differently,
I'm from Chicago and there's a restaurant
in Chicago called Alinea, and the chef there
is a person by the name of Grant Achatz.
Grant Achatz, in 2008, was named the number
one chef in the United States and last year
his restaurant, Alinea, was named the number
one restaurant in North America by restaurant
magazine.
So you say, wow a very successful person,
he's also overcome cancer in this whole process
which has been a testament to his character.
So how do you top that?
So what he decided to do was a completely
different concept when it comes to restaurants
for his next restaurant.
His new restaurant is called Next.
And Next, what they do is they have four menus
for the year.
Each of the menu's represents a different
time and a different place in history.
So Paris 1906 or Sicily 1949 or Hong Kong
2036.
And for three months, that's the menu.
You don't make a reservation, you have to
buy tickets.
Ticket prices differ based on the week of
the day and the time of the day.
So if you want tickets for Wednesday night
at nine o'clock, they're gonna be less expensive
than Saturday night at seven o'clock.
All of the cost is included within that ticket.
So when you go, you're not tipping anyone,
you're not paying extra for drinks, everything's
included.
You can also get a subscription so that you
can have tickets for each of the four.
So again we think about dining, restaurants,
very similar activities but Grant has done
it in a different way that's helped him stand
out amongst his peers.
So I'd like you to think about and if you
have a pen and paper maybe jot down, but think
about what are some of the unique traits,
activities, skills that you have that you
are able to bring value to yourself or other
people in your life?
What makes you unique?
Your talent, your passion, okay?
So think about that as you move forward.
Several years ago my wife.
Anne, and I went on a safari in Africa.
And we took a tour of a Masai Mara tribal
village led by a native guide.
And he said "The tribal leader in this village
has seven wives because the women in the village
do most of the work.
From washing the clothes in the stream to
building the huts that you see out of sticks
and cow dung."
So if you've been to Africa, some of the places,
the huts, the houses they live in are actually
made of dried cow dung which is interesting.
Anyway, were finishing up the tour and the
tribal leader, the one with seven wives emerges
from his hut and begins talking with some
of the tourists.
As we're about to leave, I notice the tribal
leader talking to my wife, Anne.
So being the interested husband I kind of
wandered over to eavesdrop on the end of the
conversation.
He said to her, "We have much work to do here
but our lives are simple and good.
I am always looking for the right people to
carry on our traditions.
I find you to be attractive and sturdy; would
you like to be one of my wives?"
Now in fairness to my wife, Anne, I think
being called sturdy in Africa is a complement
to women I'm not so sure it would be here.
[Laughter]
So after a long pause by Anne, a little too
long for my liking,
[Laughter]
she said, "You know, I love the land here,
and the animals are beautiful but seeing as
how I'm already married all respectfully have
to pass."
So on the bouncy Jeep ride back to camp I
couldn't let that conversation go without
just a little jab.
So I said, "You know, honey, it sounds like
your decision earlier boiled down to me or
a house of cow dung."
And she said, "Yes and it was much closer
than you think."
[Laughter]
Because the reality is in business and our
personal lives we're constantly faced with
trade-offs.
Trade-offs involve incompatible activities.
More of one thing means less of another.
And inherently, when we make trade-offs we're
making decisions.
So step three of our process is decide.
And the word decide or decision comes from
the Latin word decidere which means to cut
off.
If you have trees on your property you know
that every few years you've got to cut off,
you've gotta prune some of the low branches,
some of the dead branches to promote new growth.
Think about your work.
Think about your personal life.
We're very good about adding things to our
plate, but how often do we stop and actively,
consciously take things off of our plate?
Especially from a work standpoint I see it
very often.
You're adding more projects, you're adding
more work because you want to be that team
player and all the sudden your spread too
thin and you're not as valuable to your team
or the business unit as you could be because
there is no focus.
The same thing happens with our lives.
We mean well, we want to volunteer on a number
of different nonprofit opportunities.
We want to make sure we get to our kids' events.
We want to stay late and make sure we get
that project done.
But suddenly sometimes we feel like we've
spread ourselves too thin.
So we want to understand how can we focus
a little bit more on what's really valuable
to us and the people that we care about at
work and at home?
And one of the ways to do that is to come
up with a not to do list.
And this isn't a revolutionary concept.
But what I have found is I do leadership programs
on strategic thinking with managers around
the world.
What I've found is that the great managers
or leaders are the ones that are crystal clear
on what they and their teams are not going
to do.
Everybody has a to do list but the great leaders
are the ones that are crystal clear on what
they're not going to do.
So that comes to our personal lives as well.
We have to make those trade-offs otherwise
they get made for you.
Right?
And that's when we feel like we don't really
have control of what's going on, we feel like
we're spread too thin.
So one of the things you may consider doing
is a not to do list.
Look at those areas that we talked about,
look at work, what are some of the activities,
the projects, the reports, the tactics that
you think you should stop doing?
Because they're no longer bringing value.
Think about your personal life, from a financial
perspective what are areas that you're spending
money that aren't really adding value long-term
to you or the people that you care about?
So think about that not to do list that's
potentially a way to creating greater focus
not only at work but in your personal lives
as well.
When you create a house, when you create a
building, when you create a bridge generally
you start with a blueprint, right?
If you are gonna have a new house built and
you talk to the architect and they just showed
up on the job site and had people start digging
and you said, "Well, where's the blueprints?"
And he said, or she said, "We don't have a
blueprint", you'd think, “oh my God what
do you mean we don't have a blueprint?
How do we know what were actually going to
do because we don't have a blueprint?”
Yet in business and in our personal lives
a good number of folks operate without that
blueprint.
And so design is that fourth step.
Once you've kind of discovered where you are
step one, you've differentiated in step two
and thought about what are you're unique talents
and passions and how do you bring those together.
And in step three you've decided where am
I going to focus my time, my talent, and any
finances to be happy, to be successful?
Now we get to design.
Design means we need to layout that plan.
And planning in a lot of places has negative
baggage with it.
Well we develop a plan but it sits in a binder
on the shelf.
How many of you actively use your business
plans at work day in and day out to drive
your activities?
Okay, a couple people.
A lot of the Fortune 500 companies that I
do work with this is kind of the scenario.
They have a plan, it sits in a binder, sits
in a PowerPoint deck.
Here's what they do day in and day out and
there's no link.
There's no link.
So what we want to do is try and create that
link between what is the plan that we have
and what are we doing day in and day out.
And so one of the more common planning tools
that's out there is SWOT analysis and I know
SWOT analysis is the most commonly used strategic
planning tool in the world but in my opinion
it's probably the most misused.
Because we've seen SWOT analysis, strengths,
weaknesses, opportunities, threats.
We say yeah, yeah, yeah, been there done that.
But if we do it correctly we can generate
some insights and help start at least the
foundation of that plan.
And what I want to share with you today is
not just SWOT but what would you do after
a SWOT analysis to actually develop strategy
for your life.
I'll show you a quick example.
Here's a SWOT example that you might have,
strengths, weaknesses, opportunities and threats.
Strengths, coaching, maybe you do some volunteer
work with your daughter's ice-skating team
or your son's baseball team.
Maybe you like to coach maybe you're good
at that.
Maybe you're a leader at school, there's a
parent teacher organization and you do a lot
of good work with that.
Maybe you have fund-raising abilities, maybe
you're working with a couple nonprofits and
obviously as the economy has been poorer it's
difficult for nonprofits to survive so you've
used some of your fund-raising abilities that's
a strength.
Weaknesses maybe we're not as good a listener
as we could be.
Maybe we've been in a relationship for a long
time and we're not really locked in and listening
to what our partner or spouse or significant
other is saying.
Maybe we're too quick to judge folks.
A lot of times we look at somebody and you
take 10 seconds and you say I know what that
person's about.
So maybe we need to step back a little bit
there.
Maybe we're not fully engaged with family
at home, maybe work's taking over, e-mail,
texting, Twitter.
Maybe we're doing a lot of that stuff and
we're not fully engaged when we're home.
Opportunities, maybe the formation of a new
nonprofit group, training for new managers
at work, maybe there's an executive-led manager-led
class that we could be a part of.
And then maybe our daughter's interest in
art is an opportunity for us.
Threats, maybe there's some company downsizing.
Community's lack of participation.
Maybe people aren't reaching out and helping
as much as they used to with community events.
And then maybe there's a property tax increase
that financially we need to think about because
maybe that affects some of our vacation plans.
So what we can do then is once we developed
a SWOT analysis we can say how do we prioritize
the opportunities that we have?
You all have time, talent and finances to
some degree.
How do you prioritize where that goes?
You can use an opportunity matrix to do that
looking at two criteria.
What's the probability of achievement?
If I put my resources, my time, my talent,
my budget to that?
And then what's the impact on my life if I
do?
Very common tool that we use in business to
vet opportunities when you can use it in your
personal life as well.
So maybe when we plot our opportunities, we
say well the formation of the nonprofit group
the probability is not as high because that's
dependent on a lot of other people and we're
having difficulty getting people involved.
Training for new managers, maybe the probability
of the impact is a little higher there.
We've got good relationships at work.
There's a need at work so maybe we can do
that.
And then maybe the number one opportunity
is Suzy's interest in art.
She's our daughter, we're maybe not spending
as much time at home.
The impact could be great if we could find
out a way to be involved with that.
Same thing with the threats that we face and
again threats are things that potentially
can stop us from reaching our level of happiness
or success.
What's the probability that that would occur
1 to 10, what's the impact on our lives?
So again community's lack of participation,
probability is high the impact maybe not as
much on us.
The property tax increase something that we're
thinking about, the company layoffs again
maybe the biggest thing that kind of is top
of mind.
So now you say, 'okay great Rich we did the
SWOT analysis, we prioritize our opportunities
and threats so what?'
That's the biggest question I get when I do
strategic planning with companies is we did
SWOT analysis, so what?
Who cares?
We don't do anything with it.
So this last tool is a way to take your SWOT
analysis, your strengths, weaknesses, opportunities,
and threats and actually create strategies.
Okay?
I know this is a little busy but what you've
done is you have your strengths and weaknesses
at the top.
You already did that as part of your SWOT
analysis.
You have your opportunities and threats listed
on the left-hand side.
You've already created those in your SWOT
analysis.
All you're doing now is you're playing around
with the combination of your strengths and
weaknesses which are your internal capabilities,
relative to your opportunities and threats
which are your external possibilities.
So we can see if we look at our strengths
and opportunities we have leadership ability
at school, coaching, maybe we haven't really
used that at work.
So one of the opportunities is to use that
leadership ability to create a proposal to
lead one of those managerial classes at work.
If we drop down and look at strengths and
threats.
One of the strengths that we have is fund-raising
abilities so maybe we create a fund-raising
event for the community to generate greater
interest because that's a threat, the community's
lack of interest to help needy children.
So again if you do SWOT analysis as part of
your work or part of your life, this is a
way for you to line those things up to create
some strategies.
To create some direction for how you're using
your time and your talent.
Okay?
So the last step, the fifth step is drive.
When we think about the word drive, it could
have a lot of different connotations.
A very leisurely Sunday drive, maybe in the
mountains just relaxing.
Maybe you're thinking more of a Formula One
race car or NASCAR trading paint.
But the word drive really talks about, really
means to put effort forth.
To move something from one spot to another.
We can do all the thinking, we can do all
the planning we want but at the end of the
day if we don't have the preparation and the
perseverance and the will to move things forward
then we've wasted time.
I work with a lot of organizations when I
look at how they've done planning in the past,
there's no drive.
They've spent the time in the two-day off-site
meeting at the Holiday Inn twice a year but
when it comes to executing, they're not executing.
So we want to talk a little bit about what's
a way, what's a tool for us to drive success
in our personal lives and potentially at work.
And the tool that we could potentially use
is called an activity system map.
An activity system map is simply a way to
look at your life, to look at your business
on one page, one page.
And there's really two components, the first
component is your strategic themes.
Your strategic themes are the 3 to 5 areas
that really you want to invest the most resources
in to provide that value to yourself, to the
other people in your life.
So 3 to 5 areas that really you want to focus
on this year to reach your potential.
The tactics then, are the second part.
The tactics are activities are the things
that you're actually going to do to realize
those strategies.
So let's look at an example.
Our strategic themes might be empathy, teaching
and growth, as we look at our plan for 2012
on an individual level.
Empathy, teaching and growth those are our
three strategic themes.
Those are the areas we want to invest our
time and our talent into.
The tactics or activities then support those,
so for growth it might be things like committing
to exercise five days a week.
Joining Toastmasters, public speaking group
so that I can successfully lead that class
at work that I talked about earlier and maybe
researching cultures, foreign countries that
we're considering visiting so that my spouse
or partner can have a wonderful time if we
do make that trip overseas.
So individually those things don't look that
important.
But where the power comes from is when you
develop this map fully and you've said to
yourself here are the 3 to 5 areas I'm gonna
focus on and here are the actual things I'm
gonna do to realize my potential in those
areas, okay?
So empathy, practicing the active listening
at home.
Volunteering, mentoring, teaching, coaching,
fund-raising in the community.
We talked about the class and maybe learning
new subjects in summer with our kids.
Maybe that art class with Suzy that we both
take together.
So we want to think about how do we simply
capture our strategy for our life?
The activity system map is one way to help
us drive that day in and day out.
Whether it's in business or your personal
life great strategy should be simple.
I have a daughter named Jessie, she's six
years old.
And her favorite book is the Dr. Seuss book
"Green Eggs and Ham."
And if Dr. Seuss was a strategist I think
he would've written something along the lines
of, 'I am strategic, strategic I am.
Do you like to think strategically?
I do not like to think strategically not in
an office, not in a tree, it's more fun to
think tactically.
Stuff I can touch, stuff I can see.
I do not like to think strategically, I haven't
the time to be so leisurely.
Setting good brands I'll leave to others gotta
check my BlackBerry even in bed under the
covers.
[Laughter]
No I do not like to think strategically.
I prefer the adrenaline rush of mindless reactivity.
You do not like to think strategically so
you say.
Try it, try it and you may.
Say, I do like to think strategically.
While others around me only fight fires I
focus my resources taking my business higher.
I schedule time just to think.
Now my goals and strategies are in perfect
sync.
Strategic I am.'
So the bottom line is we need to keep strategy
simple if we're actually going to do it day
in and day out.
The reality is if you don't carve out time
in your schedule either individually or with
other people to think about your work, to
think about your life, it's going to happen
to you.
It may happen well and it may not happen so
well.
And are there going to be unexpected things
that happen along the way?
Absolutely.
But if you have no direction, if you haven't
channeled what you're good at, what you're
passionate about, then you've wasted your
potential.
Michelangelo was quoted as saying, "A person
paints with their mind not with their hands."
We live in an action-oriented world, but never
forget that your success in business and your
personal life begins here first.
Give yourself permission, time and tools to
think strategically.
Strategy is the bridge from where you are
today to where you want to go.
Without that bridge, you have no way of successfully
spanning the gaps in your life.
Without that bridge, you don't have a way
to overcome the barriers in certain cases.
But with that strategy or with that bridge,
you have the power to go from where you are
today to where you want to go.
The question is will you use your potential
to reach that destination?
What I'd like to do now is open it up for
any comment, any questions, any thoughts that
you might have.
I always enjoy hearing from people, how they've
approached planning whether it's for their
business or for their personal lives and an
opportunity to maybe share some best practices.
So we do, there's a microphone here or we
can just pop up.
>>female #1: [Inaudible]
>>Rich: Yeah, so the question was once you
develop your strategy.
You know that's one thing but how do you get
that resolution to kind of see it through?
A lot of people make New Year's resolutions
right?
And it's the beginning of March and probably
for a lot of people, they're sort of gone
now.
So the question becomes how do we stay focused
on it?
I'm a big believer in the fact that concepts
change thinking and tools change behavior.
So if you're gonna change your behavior, if
you're gonna actually follow through on your
strategies you have to have a tool.
Something like an activity system map with
the three bubbles that sits on your desk or
sits on your nightstand or on your bathroom
counter that you're looking at on a regular
basis to trigger that change in behavior.
If you don't have a way in your environment
to change that behavior it's not gonna happen.
So the best successes I've heard from people
are to have a trigger that changes behavior.
Something like the activity system map can
do that for you.
Thank you.
Other comments, thoughts?
Okay.
Well, I'll stick around, oh, I'm sorry yeah.
>>male #1: Can you show what to do with his
web analysis again?
You had this chart with weaknesses and such.
>>Rich: Yeah,
>>male #1: That one.
>>Rich: This one?
>>male #1: That one, yes.
>>Rich: Yeah, so what you're doing is you're
lining up your strengths and weaknesses, and
your opportunities and threats.
And you're just using these four boxes as
kind of a methodical way to think through.
So this box your meshing your strengths and
your opportunities together.
So you're saying here are the things I can
take advantage of, how can I do that with
what I'm good at?
If we go down here, we're matching our strengths
and our threats.
So these are things potentially that can prevent
us from being happy or successful.
How do we use our strengths to prevent those
things from derailing our efforts?
So you're just using these four boxes as kind
of a trigger to think through what you're
good at or where you have weaknesses, what
you can take advantage of and what can hurt
you.
>>male #1: Thank you.
Yeah.
>>Alex: So hello?
So my name is Alex Arris.
>>Rich: Hi Alex.
>>Alex: Thank you for coming and giving this
talk.
I very much empathize with you about strategies
and the importance of them and being organized
and having an orderly life or something.
I doubt that every person is like that.
>>Rich: You're right, very few, 15%.
>>Alex: And I don't know what to do with that,
but you may know better.
So one thing is that I have used strategies
even though I am like an organized person,
I felt disappointed.
>>Rich: Okay.
>>Alex: So one strategy that I used was in
order to become a professor, I applied to
universities and I had this strategy.
I had tactics, maybe informally, not written
down, or actually written down but in other
terms.
>>Rich: Okay.
>>Alex: So I applied to five universities
every week, I ended up applying to 72 universities,
I got one phone interview which nothing happened.
And, but I got an offer from Google after
things that I have not planned at all like
someone referred me.
I got a call.
I miss that call.
They called me again I went back another time
and then I don't know.
They were very interested.
I couldn't say no.
I came gave it a chance and now I'm here.
>>Rich: Okay.
>>Alex: So I just wanted, maybe that's a comment
maybe you can comment on it but I have another
thing to.
So that's more like a question.
What do you do when you plan out the strategy
or tactic and then you have all that work
done and you just find that you don't want
to do it?
I had forced myself to do it.
It was hard, didn't work.
>>Rich: Yeah, so to both of those things and
thank you very much I think they're both a
great comment and a great question.
I think the reality is that the first step
that we talked about, discover.
You've got understand what's your purpose.
And I'm a big believer in identify what's
your purpose in life, why are you here?
To your point, that purpose may translate
into a lot of different things.
Maybe it's a professor, maybe it's not.
Maybe it's a leader here at Google, maybe
it's not.
So you've got to find your purpose, how that
actually gets translated into the real world
to your point is gonna be a surprise sometimes.
And that's fine.
But what I see too often is people moving
from one spot to another with no idea of what
their purpose is.
Meaning where that intersection of talent
and passion and knowledge and skill is.
Because if you understand what that is you
can bring value to a lot of people whether
it's for-profit or nonprofit.
But the key is to first uncover that.
So it sounds like you've uncovered it, and
there's channels and I talk in the book about
your purpose channels.
So one channel might be professor but you
haven't pursued that yet.
But that's not to say in 10 years you may
be a professor.
But right now the channel is Google and the
question is for you moving forward is how
do you maximize that at Google?
So excellent points thank you very much.
>>Alex: Sure.
Appreciate it.
Any other comments, thoughts?
No?
Okay, well, thanks very much I hope you have
a great rest of the day folks.
Thanks.
[Applause]